how odd it is to once again be going
places and to feel like
is this
is this like 2019
is this like
2023 will this last
one of the things that you said
uh to me when we were in santa barbara
so we were in santa barbara we were
invited
to go
by bishop robert baron
who has a podcast and a youtube channel
you know he he he and his people he is a
catholic bishop in gosh i hope i get
this right the archdiocese of los
angeles i believe
who's based in santa barbara and who has
been basically trying to get the word
out and to interact with people not just
who are already um in the fold um with a
youtube channel from the very early days
of youtube um and we had you know off
camera we had some really wonderful
conversations with with him and and some
of the people whom he works with but he
had his own he had us on his show word
on fire
word on fire words on fire word on fire
uh and it was it was remarkable
i can say that if you um got
the description of his position in the
church incorrect i'm pretty sure he will
forgive you i can't tell you how i know
that but it just it's a sense that i
have about him yeah he's he's an
extraordinary man he really is uh and we
my internet has stopped working that's a
really good moment for that to happen
um
we also spent an extra day down there uh
you know we could have flown down and
just had dinner and and
spent the night and gone to his studio
and then you know we had lunch
we'd lunch with him as well and then
flow right back but we actually spent an
extra day so we got to see a little bit
of santa barbara which i
i went to ucsb briefly you know a couple
per couple years right at the beginning
of my college experience but ucsb is 12
miles or so
outside of santa barbara and santa
barbara is itself a
very fancy little enclave in southern
california but far enough outside of la
to really have reminded us almost not at
all of la yeah it's like what la wants
to be yeah it's really i mean you know
there's the
vegetation on the hills which is
reminiscent but i really find almost
almost nothing about it yeah similar to
the feeling of l.a but one of the things
you said was it felt like um
it felt like a lot of the people were
missing
yeah and now so now i've had a couple of
trips and i'm i'm
you know it's hard to separate because
two things have happened one the
population
has been through something we've all
been through something together and then
you and i have been through something
that most people
don't have an inkling of
who aren't you know on the wrong end of
and all of that
and so you know one has to separate how
is it is the feeling that is so
different here about what's here is it
about me
what exactly is that but there is a
i would say for me it has been
um
it has been
delightful
eerie and poignant all at the same time
right to travel
again
to see places you haven't done before
and i i
can't say but i feel like this is some
sort of you know
uh
uh an intermission
right between acts of something
which makes it all the more poignant
because
you know to the extent that we have just
discovered how disconnected we can
become from each other how you know
borders that never mattered before like
the canadian border to an american
citizen suddenly become impenetrable
right and if you're canadian and are
unvaccinated you are still um denied
many of your rights right and so
i feel
a couple things one i feel
that um we are traveling in a
transformed world right and that you
know people
i almost felt people are
traumatized
they're very relieved you know every so
often you meet somebody
who's been tortured right and they're
out and you think you know you hear the
stories of what they went through and
you think
i just don't even know how a person
processes that
but it is evident that a person can
process it and they can live again and
they can have joy and they can laugh and
all of those things but they are never
the same right you've seen what what can
be done to you
and this isn't that obviously we were
not
uh tortured but we were i think
psychologically you know i wish we had
you know 40 words for gaslit the way
inuits apparently do not really for snow
but
the apocryphal accounting has it that
they do we need 50 words for gaslit
because this isn't all uh of the
identical thing but right to the extent
that we are being told that we must
accept nonsense again and again on a
dozen different topics
and then punished if we start asking
questions that is a kind of
um
it is a traumatizing phenomenon and i
believe one can feel it as you travel
someplace yes there's a tentativeness
about people
living yes i i absolutely agree and it's
actually one of the things that was so
um
remarkable about bishop baron and all of
the people whom he is working with on
his team that um you know we
we were invited there as evolutionary
biologists um to a group of people who
have explicit faith for whom faith is
absolutely central in their lives and it
went in knowing
that on this point we do not see
the world to the same lens
but on so many other points we do
and that the one point on which
you know which could be construed is
utterly fundamental
actually does not preclude us from
conversing and agreeing and
coming to have great respect and
admiration from for one another on so
many other points as in fact i think we
did reveal in the conversation certainly
in the conversations that we had off
camera but i hope in the conversation we
had on camera as well yeah i think
it's really
a lot has been lost recently but this is
one of the things that has been
i think achieved largely in the last
five years
um there is a way and i you know i i
hope that we have significantly
contributed to this i think that may be
the case and that's part of why
you know we've been invited to talk to
people such as bishop barron but
there is a recognition
amongst especially people on the
religious side that um
it doesn't have to be that those on the
scientific side are the enemy and in
fact you know there's a great deal of
reason to think that that's not the case
at all right and it just involves
you know let's put it this way when we
talk about metaphorical truth
we are saying something that could be
read hostilely if you were in you know
if you were of a mindset to view that as
an accusation you certainly could on the
other hand if you have you know a broad
i mean and i think
almost all
thinking religious people have to have a
somewhat broad mindset because they're
living under circumstances that don't
look anything like the circumstances
described in their texts and so you know
that's there's a profound question in
that did god
intend you to live by rules that made a
lot of sense in you know an ancient
world in which nobody spoke the language
you speak or is there some amount of
flexibility is you know is the church a
living entity because it has to be in
order to adjust
you know the religious uh doctrine for
the modern world and so what that means
is not that we come to agreement but
it's like
you know sometimes people ask us
you know they never say it in these
terms but it's sort of like um
[Music]
you know oh
you're an evolutionary biologist well
then how did life begin you know and
it's like well
i gotta tell you
really don't know
you know there are some things that make
more sense and some things that make
lessons but that's one of those things
that we might just never find out
because right there's not a whole lot of
evidence you know the evidence is very
indirect that it has been
that has persisted for uh three and a
half billion years
um so anyway the point is all of us have
stuff at the very
very edge of the thing that we care
deeply about that we may you know
effectively have to be agnostic about
and that allows religious people and and
scientifically
focused people
to you know talk about most issues
without ever touching on it absolutely
and i think um you know another thing
that became
more clear for me um associated with
both
um talking with bishop baron and the
other people whom we were talking with
there and just then walking around
talking with you in the aftermath of
that
considering what we had heard and what
we had intuited from what we heard is
that okay
be you in a secular landscape as we are
or in a religious landscape as they are
you're likely to have in every other
regard all of the same diversity of
opinions
and uh and demographics and so for
instance
uh you know we you know part of how
what happened five years ago this week
when evergreen publicly blew up in a
fury of misplaced outrage and you know
absurd chaos
um was
about the so-called left having lost its
grip on reality in part right and
uh
you know there are there are those of us
and we are certainly not alone who you
know since before then have been saying
actually the best way to go forward into
a future that is as post-racial as
possible is not to keep pointing out how
how bad everyone is to one another based
on race like that's that's not going to
be helpful um and there are those of
course who um say that they're on the
left who say that by saying that you are
demonstrating that you're not on the
left yourself and that you are yourself
um on the right
similarly there will be those on the
right who will say look if you're not
you know if if you are
arguing for anything that sounds uh like
giving in to these people then you're
not really on the right and maybe you're
one of them and i'm like that's that's
much more of a caricature of position
because i don't i don't hear that as
much because we don't claim to be on the
right because we're not
um but i get the sense that um within
the religious community there are people
that are hard right and hard left and
you know woke catholics exist
and um very conservative catholics exist
and there are tensions pulling people in
both directions there just as there are
for those of us who don't exist within
the religious context but are sort of in
in the wider world and so you know the
the
the fight against woke ideology in favor
of an actual liberal understanding of
the world
is not constrained to being one of
either an explicit religious or an
explicitly non-religious context
and that is part of the the lesson of
talking to people who would appear to
have some fundamental difference with
you is where you find all the other
commonalities and all the other ways
that you can actually cross lines and
find ways to talk to them
now
that description
suggests
something to me that i have not
considered before i'm sort of surprised
because thematically it's very much like
many thoughts that i've expressed
but i'm feeling at this moment if you
take our description of much of the
orthodoxy that accompanied the cove
pandemic
as which we have described as medically
work yep
and then you invoke that actually um
with bishop parent i believe yeah and i
must say i invoked at the conference too
and people resonate with us for those of
us who
felt this
the analogy was awfully close
you know the conference that you were at
in bath which you haven't introduced
yeah explained yet
um but in any case the question is
in one way
woke is a kind of contagion and
medically woke is a kind of contagion
right it is a set of ideas that spread
horizontally for reasons that are not
about the reality of what's being
described
okay you know contagious
uh
cluster of ideas and assumptions
um but
i guess the question is all right if you
have two
earth transforming
contagions like this that come in quick
succession
it raises the possibility that these
things are downstream
of a change in the rules
a loss of immunity actually
that would allow such things to catch on
where they would have been tamped down
by normal
homeostatic processes in your culture
beforehand and i guess you could you
could phrase that as a change in the
rules or a release on the idea that
rules are a good idea
and you know the release on the idea
that i that rules themselves are a good
idea sort of how a lot of the
the woke left is framing their
preferences you know no more police
no more you know no restrictions on
people you're just going to let them do
what they're gonna do um so but it's not
libertarian it's the opposite
that's that's the confusing thing about
it it is the suspension of those rules
and it is the imposition of these rules
generated by some
undemocratic anti-democratic
anti-analytical
mechanism that defines the thing right
it's like suddenly you don't have free
speech censorship is good right and what
will be censored is now
the result of some murky process inside
some corporation
that happens completely arbitrarily and
not only or
say our truth or suffer the consequences
yes or you know certain people can say
certain things but other people can't
say the same thing i mean it's just some
sort of impossibly baroque set of new
rules that you that you know their their
defining characteristic is that they're
never spelled out so that you could even
follow them if you wanted to
right or
often there are mutually exclusive sets
of rules uh which
you you have to be one of the chosen
ones in order to use these ones um but
you know if you're the riff-raff then
then you're restricted to these yeah
and those who would make jokes about
recognizing hypocrisy or of course nazis
or something right but it is you know
i guess the question is
it was supposed to be the case that if
you were going to have a major change in
the way we governed ourselves you would
have to talk about it you would have to
convince a certain number of people that
it was a good idea so that the change
that was necessary was made and then
good or bad the new thing would happen
and now it is all bypassed that process
right and it's like
you know i'm i'm constantly struck by
the fact that i go into you know the dmv
and i'm
i'm asked by sex and there are only two
choices and that works pretty well for
me
but
i thought i was told pretty well
well enough i mean
let's put it this way i you know my
answer hasn't changed in all of the
years i've had a driver's license i have
noticed right and uh my point would be
that
either
that is a
spectacular failure of the dmv to keep
up on the latest science
[Laughter]
or
there's some bureaucracy that's just
stodgy enough not to have been afflicted
with this thing i mean
i don't know what it means but you know
even
come on no i don't
i want to hear this
i don't know what i don't know what
there is to say i guess my feeling is
we're just caught in a world where you
know
somehow the dmv is not constantly beset
by
protesters
as you might expect based on their
transgression yeah whereas almost any
any survey that you fill out from a
school or uh i would think most sort of
conferences although probably not the
conference you were just at
um and certainly not the little
conference that i was at for the
university of austin but many
many such places will now offer you um
you're not the full panoply of eight
thousand possible choices but you know
at least you know a few and then another
and you know maybe a space to fill in
your explanation for you
male female and don't go their
girlfriend
right
[Music]